-Do you ever see a photo in the news
and think that headline should be different?
Well, we'll take care of that right now.
It's time for "News and Improved." Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example, check out -- check out this first photo here.
The original headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"No one's getting fired."
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ] "Oh, yeah. This was back..."
-"I coulda. I didn't. But I coulda."
-"I didn't, but I coulda."
"Are you sure?"
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Wow!
That's a headline.
-Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
[ Applause ]
-And finally, this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all the time we have for "News and Improved." We have a great show.